[Music]
right
uh welcome to my version of the hot
wings you've seen me on first we feast
and
those incredible wings but i'm going to
show you how i do
a take on a amazon inspired wing
okay first off we've got these amazing
chicken wings okay
beautiful seasoning scallions they're
gonna make uh almost like a salsa with a
mango onions
and these little things here these are
the weary weary pepper
super hot they look like little cherry
tomatoes but trust me they
are incredibly delicious i'll make a bit
of a salsa with garlic ginger
tomatoes and then this this is a unique
very tart it's almost like a molasses
kazreep so it's a very dark beautiful
molasses kazreep
but i'm gonna glaze
the wings with that at the end first off
and put the wings on okay
so wings beautifully seasoned salt
pepper
okay and then from there a little bit of
olive oil
now sometimes when the wings are that
big
okay in order to make sure they get
cooked just get a knife
and just literally pierce them with a
knife
okay and that makes sure
that they cook inside the bone
just go through with the knife pierce
them
and that helps cook the wing right
into the bone really important onto the
grill
okay start off with a really nice color
beautiful
nice now on there
let them grill now
first off get these little weary weary
peppers
okay take the
core off and just cut them in half take
off the
little cork and slice them in half
okay i need about three now
in they look like little cherry tomatoes
they're so delicious
from their slice of garlic
nice and thin here we go
and then a little bit of ginger
again in
give that a nice little season
and just start to sort of pound that
here you press the water and just turn
that into a really nice paste
nice now that's the base
okay let's check those wings
now beautiful wings
nice thing about the chickens here
they're so fat so you get a really nice
color on them okay
[Music]
and a little piercing really does help
tremendously
i'm gonna make a really nice salsa and
then it gives it that nice sort of
zesty flavor
slice that down
up
now from there we'll sweeten that up a
little bit
and get some beautiful chopped tomatoes
chopped tomatoes help take away some of
that heat
but there's a really nice little
sweetness
to it as well
[Music]
fresh lime in there
and then top that up with a little touch
of olive oil
now think about it the garlic the tomato
the onion
and that beautiful pepper
now we need a bit of sort of sweetness
in there
beautiful mango literally from the tree
50 meters from here now from there
okay chop this up
and that's going to give a really nice
sweet flavor to the salsa
and then finally take a little touch of
the scallions
and that's going to lift that flavor up
even more but i want the whites of the
scallions these bits here
okay so take that up
literally
that's going to bring this salsa to life
onions are marinaded and the scallions
go
right at the very end now
this is wild time okay
i'm just gonna pick these little leaves
and put those leaves in there
now get your kissery just a tablespoon
in there see how thick that is
i'm going to glaze that open my wings
now
watch
it gives that really nice dark color to
the wings
just let that down with a little touch
of olive oil
seasoning you can see it's almost like a
molasses
but it's a really nice flavor to the
chicken
the dark in the wings those little pores
and those wonderful little holes i put
in the chicken to help marinate it
great way of cooking and also now it's
going to roll it on the grill now
so that kasuri that's easily caramelized
and look what happens now let's start to
caramelize
and take on different color
now take them off
get them into the bowl color them so
tasty really packed full of flavor
then beautiful
[Music]
now the exciting part
take a nice spoon
of your salsa in
and just glaze that over there
okay and now
just want those the wings
rolled oh my god smelling there
it's incredible and then to serve a nice
spoon
on
beautiful color
height
and then just
drizzle down on top and that casual just
literally sort of melts
and finally some scallions
and there we are beautiful hot wings
jungle style
finish the most amazing kazareep
there you go sean stick that in your
pipe and smoke it
that is what you call a hot wing let me
know in the comments what you think of
that amazing dish
and if you missed uncharted trust me you
can watch it
on the link below or on the nat geo app